Valerie Bertinelli catches alleged
burglars on a camera outside her home in
a post to her Instagram Story the star
revealed her neighborhood had
experienced a string of robberies and
shared video footage and photos of two
men she alleges are burglars Valerie
says the suspicious men came to scope
out her house Tuesday night but thanks
to her home security system one man
stopped as he saw the camera according
to Valerie the police quickly arrived at
the scene checking her home and those
around her and now safety's at the top
of Valerie's mind she says she's
installing motion detector lights and
even thinking of putting barbed wire on
her front fence as an extra precaution
it's all in the journey it truly is this
comes after Valerie finalized her
divorce from Tom Vitale last month on 11
22 22 I am officially divorced
the actress was elated as she entered
single hood for the first time since
marrying Tom back in 2011.
finally
it's finally over
and seems Valerie's totally ready for
the single life I mean I am going to be
more than happy to be happily divorced
and spend the rest of my life alone I'll
be happy that way well with my six cats
and my dog and my son and hopefully one
day grandchildren well one thing
Valerie's not changing being a proud
mama and I was Wolfie's mom before even
Wolfie was you know famous so now
Wolfie's famous I feel like I'm latching
onto his coattails now she was beaming
With Pride over her son Wolfgang
following in his late dad Eddie Van
Halen's footsteps after he performed at
the Taylor Hawkins tribute concert
[Applause]
I was there at Wembley I was spectacular
yeah I've never been so proud and I'm
sure I'll be proud again and Shane on
the drums I was the two of the moments
that I was sobbing
but it was total Water Works for Valerie
back in April when Wolfgang nabbed his
first Grammy nomination it is really
emotional I mean the song that Wolfie
wrote is just such a absolutely stunning
gorgeous song and um it's really
beautiful that he was honored for it and
for songwriting because that's the first
thing that really stuck out to me is
like Wolfie you're a songwriter that's
the hardest part of being a musician
well being here tonight and thinking
about what this would mean to your dad
would he would be losing his mind
but also at the same time he'd be like
duh because that's how much he believed
in me yeah yeah so uh yeah this is
absolutely insane no words all I can say
is in spite of me and Ed we got this and
I am so proud of him
foreign